[Music]
the curse
has been broken the dynasty
has been cemented they are the greatest
monster in call of duty history
gaming are officially the call of duty
world league champions
optic gaming was one of the most beloved
teams in esports history
after a year of pain
there it is optic gaming
back on top they were a pillar of the
call of duty community
led by one of the most well-respected
figures in the industry and they had
some of the most devoted fans in the
world
but one day optic suddenly fell apart
he's like they're gonna find a home for
the call of duty players within the next
two weeks
and i'm like i seriously might my my
heart dropped
and i was like i cannot believe that
they're not even gonna give me a chance
2018 was supposed to be the year that
optic took things to the next
level instead it marked the beginning of
the end for one of esports greatest
organizations i remember walking in
seeing the allegiance flag and i pointed
at him what the [ __ ] is that
why is there another team's flag in my
offices
[Music]
today optic gaming los angeles is a team
in the call of duty world league
but it's optic in name alone with new
management and players
optic la is a shallow husk of its former
self
a team that just a few years ago was
considered an
industry titan and could bring out fans
in droves
an org that went from sniping montages
on youtube to being named the best
esports team of the year
an org once led by hector rodriguez
better known
as hex
[Music]
if you don't know who hex is the dude is
the personification of hard work
despite having a financially difficult
childhood hex grinded his way to a life
of a luxury in the early 2000s by
climbing the ranks of the insurance
industry
i said all right i'm going to work with
money i'm going to work in a bank
so i worked at a bank as a teller and
then from there i was like an assistant
personal banker
from there i went to work at a in a call
center for harris remember harrisbank
i think it's [ __ ] now yeah yeah all right
so harris and then from there i went
into the mortgage industry from 2000 and
[Music]
to 2000 to whenever it blew up the the
mortgage industry because of something
it was super hot at that time but hexa's
lifestyle took a pretty big hit
after the financial crisis of 2008. i
dropped from making
130 to 150 you know depending on bonuses
on
how good i was to 45 a year
and i had to give back i had to i
couldn't afford
my at the time i had a navigator and my
and my girl whose wife now had to give
back her mercedes
but amidst all this hardship hex
unknowingly took a step
into an industry that would change his
life again for me it was it was nothing
to do with business
it had everything to do with like
creating cool videos that had to do with
call of duty and it was a montage called
um
techno prisoners or something like that
it was a call of duty 4 montage
and that was it from there pex found his
way to optic
gaming so you didn't found optic did jay
found it i don't know my history
uh i think it was like three people okay
um
how did you lead it uh everybody left
and it was just me so at that time i'm
like all right i'm gonna recruit my
brother
i'm gonna recruit that and then my
brother's like we should make videos on
youtube the way that you know chris is
making and
i'm like i'm like yeah we should we're
good with the sniper yeah so we're like
we the whole sniper team became a thing
just by happenstance that we just all
liked the sniper rifle
and while optic may have started out as
a sniping clan they quickly expanded
into esports
starting a team that featured future
superstars gujar's gotta find clay sir
claisen's gonna look
and he gets the kill and optic gaming
wins it
up to gaming your x games gold medal
champion
what a performance here from optics
but optic wasn't just killing it in
terms of tournament results
see hex knew that to be a truly great
team you needed more than just
wins you needed the fans to truly
connect with the players and
feel like they were part of something
bigger than just themselves
you needed the green wall you know
because of that sort of culture that we
created we also wanted to give something
to
to the to the fans something that they
could be a part of a
again not to relate to gang or anything
but a group
a family that they could be a part of
that that
directly coincides and is is a direct
sort of you know part of the business
part of the group part of the family and
and that's what the green wall was
so while optic dazzled fans with their
in-game skills on stage
they also made them laugh with their
content and hex was a huge part of that
too
there were houses before in esports but
it was purely competition
and i think that you had a vision for
optic gaming and for that house
specifically that i think a lot of us
that were a part of the team saw because
we all believed in it enough to actually
move in
i was already streaming on on on justin
tv before that and then it switched over
to twitch
you know i had a couple hundred viewers
but when we finally made it to the optic
gaming team house russell drive 60 50
that's when everything exploded
and you were the driving force behind
that but managing this kind of team was
expensive especially back then in the
early days of esports when sponsorships
weren't as lucrative as they are today
so hex had to make some sacrifices you
know those
countless years where jude and i were
just [ __ ] stressed out where i was
yeah you're running at a loss because
you believe in what yeah yeah yeah
and and and so you know i would i would
pay myself like the
the very least that i could to do that
and all the sponsorship money would go
into
you know salaries and expansion salaries
and expansion but those sacrifices paid
off
the optic brand grew expanding into more
and more games
spray comes through royce gets a kill
and ladies and gentlemen optic gaming
your winners of e-league season two this
one's
over two one there you
have it ladies and gentlemen
opting gaming at your 2017
halo world champions
they may give it one last go they won't
they'll tap out gt
is called optic gaming chamber series
2-0 and we'll be moving forward
but as the esports industry continue to
grow certain people started to take
notice people with very deep pockets
suddenly all sorts of esports teams were
flush with venture capital cash
orgs like immortals were literally built
on investment money
sure optic were still a successful team
but all the success in the world
can't compete with millionaires who are
willing to drop fat stacks on top
players
expensive facilities and high-end
content people forget of how much of a
low point it was at
yeah and and we needed something we
needed because everybody else was
getting these huge investments
and they were getting these big teams
these winning teams and we were
kind of just yeah on the downfall in all
fronts
while he held out as long as he could
hex knew that if he wanted to compete in
this new esports landscape
he needed more money so in 2017 he went
out looking for investors
enter infinite esports at first
infinite looked like an incredible
opportunity for hex the investors were
the real deal
one was even the co-owner of the texas
rangers the reason that i chose to
step back was to create content and have
fun
right without the worry of of
spreadsheets and without the worry of
any of that [ __ ] but as soon as hex
got back from his vacation
he knew something was wrong i remember
walking in
seeing the allegiance flag and i pointed
at him what the [ __ ] is that
why is there another team's flag in my
offices
right why right right because up until
the point they hadn't told me that they
were gonna
pick up all these other teams for
whatever [ __ ] reason
right infinite tried to expand optic
fast
and i'm not just talking about the
multi-million dollar slots they bought
in both the lcs
and the overwatch league infinite bought
up entire esports teams
obey and allegiance and hired a huge
staff for their texas office
and immediately i'm just like
we don't need this many people and i
didn't see it like we don't need these
i saw it as like oh my god these people
are setting themselves up for
something bad you know what i'm saying
and what happened you know
eventually they purge yeah a purge
happened
and that is unfair and that is
wrong yeah for people to lose their jobs
right and during this obsessive period
of expansion
optics culture was lost traditions were
being thrown away and the higher-ups
didn't seem to care
there was a jersey on the [ __ ] board
right okay
and i'm like oh cool what is that is
that what is that league of legends
because i understood that the illegal
agent was gonna have to get their own
[ __ ] right they're like no no this is
this is going to be the new things it's
going to be the 2018 so like we dropped
the 2018 said november of 2017
like we have for the past 10 years that
you're not you're not throwing that
right and he's like
yeah it's just that we're going to own
the rights to this one because we don't
own the rights to the other one
where you know this other merch company
owns it i'm like
no i own everything right we're gonna
keep this jersey for the remainder of
the year
and that's that and then he's like oh
you know i'm being told other otherwise
and i'm like but i'm yeah i'm the boss
right
okay yeah i don't care who's above you
on on on a chart you know what i'm
saying i built this [ __ ]
infinite's aggressive expansion was
burning tons of money
and apparently it was unsustainable you
have to try
to to mess up options you gotta try
really hard
no but they didn't they didn't it was
just it came natural to them
all of a sudden optic had to let go of
both teams and staff
infinite even wanted to get rid of the
org's cod team
and they said i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] we're not dropping that team if you
drop the team i'm leaving too
and if i leave everybody else is gonna
leave too
finally after spending a lot of 2018
continuously downsizing
infinite threw up their hands and said
screw it they started looking for a
buyer for optic in early 2019
and hex was first in a line to try to
buy his baby back
seven months ago i promised a group and
i said
let me get optic back i wasn't asking
for a discount i was trying to make
them some money so they you know
whatever we give it a good run
but hex had stiff competition other
esports orgs wanted to buy the optic
brand
including immortals who were backed by
some serious investors
i would assume texas esports would wish
to sell to immortals gaming club because
of the
of the track record of those investors
versus if uh selling back to hacker
which is just a dude
right their option is they could sell
back to a dude or they could sell to igc
and have the cloud of selling it and
exiting to a company
which vcs care a lot about uh that has
like aeg and like lionsgate behind them
they're obviously gonna sell with igc
even if hector offers more
and in june 2019 immortals won the optic
sweepstakes
beating out hex so hex had a choice
on one hand he could stick with
immortals he'd basically be in the same
position he was with
infinite sure he'd be around he'd be the
face but he wouldn't have control
the suits would still make all the calls
or
he could do something different hex
joined nrg
as their new co-ceo and he pretty much
took the entire green wall with him
because those fans were not going to
stand behind the new optic
it's their optic now make some noise for
optic
la
these days hex is living his best life
making content and building teams
including nrg's cod team the chicago
huntsman
15 seconds on the clock mathematically
it
is done optic is done
huntsman take a convincing 3-0
and show who's on top
the tragedy of optic is a cautionary
tale a warning about how investors can
destroy a team that was once considered
an industry
giant how big money sometimes can't
understand a team
built by and for the fans but heck
survived all that
he refused to tap out and while the
optic he built might be dead
he's doing his best to keep the green
wall alive
forever thanks for watching if you want
more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
you